- Every single human being has value
and my value is not
determined on how I look
or what job I have.
You know, so many people
put me down and say
Nick you look too weird
and no one's really a friend and
you can't do this and you can't do that.
And for three months he
would chase after me and say
Nick go speak, go speak, go speak
and I said no, no, no, no,
and finally he twisted my arm, I said yes.
You're going to take three
seconds I'm going to tell you
something discouraging but then
you may never forget my words.
- He's an Australian,
Christian, Evangelist,
and motivational speaker.
He was born with a rare
disorder which left him
without any arms or legs.
He founded Attitude is Altitude,
a secular motivational speaking company.
He's Nick Vujicic and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Number two is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
(beat)
- Every single human being has value and
my value is not determined on
how I look or what job I have,
or where I'm from or where I was born,
how much money, all that stuff is nothing.
So many teenagers you know,
tease each other for how we look
and I tell the teenagers "Do
you think that I'm cool enough
to be your friend", they're
like "Yeah of course."
Said "But I have no arms, no legs."
They said "Doesn't matter."
I said "Really so it
doesn't matter that I have
no arms, no legs?"
They said "No it doesn't matter."
I said "Then actually
if it doesn't matter,
then why do we kill each
other with our words
if it actually doesn't matter?
Why do we look ourselves in the mirror
and see ugly instead of valuable?"
Want to ask you today,
what are you looking for?
If I gave you a billion
dollars, would you be happy?
If you gave me a billion
dollars, I'd be very happy.
(laughter)
But then if my mum dies
tonight am I happy?
No, with all the money in
the world I'd never be happy.
Right cause money is something
that cannot heal the soul.
You know so many people
put me down and say
Nick you look too weird
and no one's really friend
and you can't do this
and you can't do that.
And I couldn't change anything.
It's not like just fixing my hair one day
and everything's fine.
It's not like you know just whatever,
I couldn't change my circumstance.
I couldn't just one day wake up and say
hey give me arms and legs,
I need arms and legs.
You know what I mean like ...
I went to a body builder you know and said
can you make me some arms and
legs, it's no joking. (laughs)
Body builder you get it?
(laughter)
Right, so here's the thing,
you know I go up to people
can you give me a hand, you
know just joking. (laughs)
But it was so hard
because people put me down
and I started believing
that I was not good enough.
I started believing that I was a failure.
That I'd never ever be
somebody who people would like
or people would accept.
And it was so hard man,
I thought to myself
you know I can't go on the
soccer field like everybody else
and I can't ride my bike
and I can't skateboard
and all these sort of things.
And I started getting depressed.
I thought what kind of
purpose do I have to live
I mean, are you just here to live to die?
I mean, is there not a purpose for me?
Is there not a purpose in life?
And I had questions and no answers
and I asked my mom and
dad why did this happen?
I asked doctors why did this
happen and they don't know.
There are some things in life
that are out of your control
that you can't change and
you've got to live with.
The choice that we have
though is either to give up
or keep on going.
I want to ask you, what
are you going to believe?
Are you going to believe in yourself?
You going to believe everyone
elses judgment on you?
Are you going to believe
people when they say
that you're a failure, when
no one really likes you,
no one really cares about you?
It's not really to say that
hey you need someone to come up
and say hey really, I like
you, I care about you.
You know it's not that but
it's the fact that people put you down.
People don't even look you in the eye.
People ask you how you
are and you say fine
but you're not find and
they'll never know that.
Life is life.
Life is an interesting
journey of ups and downs.
But how that journey
ends is up to you today.
You see when you fall down
and you feel like giving up,
When times get tough, it's not the end.
The question is, are you
going to finish strong.
The definition of a disability is
something that will hinder you
from being able to do something.
I think though the greatest disability
is not having no arms and no legs.
The greatest disability is your mind,
the choices that you make.
The question is are you going
to make the right choices?
Are you going to make the
choice to have your life
in it's right perspective?
Are you going to make the choice
to get up instead of give up?
Are you going to make
the choice to dream big?
There is no greater disability
that we have in our life
then to make the decision to give up.
Because once you give up,
then there is no hope.
But until you give up, there is that hope.
Do you think I'm going to love my son even
though if he one day wanted to be a CEO
and becomes a janitor at a college.
Yeah, you want to know why?
Cause a janitor changed my life.
He was the first guy that said "Hey Nick,
you're going to be a speaker."
And I said "Mr. Arnold,
you're a crazy old man."
(laughter)
I said "What am I going to speak about."
He said "You're going
to share your story."
I said "I don't have a story."
He said "Yes you do."
I said "No I don't."
He said "Nick you know what,
you're here in high school.
You got to go speak at
that spiritual group."
I'm like no way am I doing that.
No way, I'm not speaking
to those ten people.
I'm not going to go to the
Christian nerd section.
(laughter)
And for three months he
would chase after me and say
Nick go speak, go speak, go speak.
And I said no, no, no, no, no.
And finally he twisted my arm I said yes.
(laughter)
And I went there and I
spoke for a couple minutes
and I saw a girl crying and
I'm like "Are you okay?"
She said "Uh huh."
(laughter)
I said "What's wrong?"
She says "Nothing."
(laughter)
I said "Why you crying?"
She said "I was just touched."
And I'm thinking, who touched her?
(laughter)
I tell you life is interesting.
Life's a journey.
See this phone here.
Let's say that I want to
go to the phone right?
And I start from over here.
Now to get to the phone,
it's not like I'm going
to start meditating
and going hum right and
float across the air right?
That's not going to work.
It's not like I'm going
to go hum mm and woo,
you know it's not going to work.
So I have to take one step at
a time, one step at a time,
one step at a time.
You can only take one step at a time.
I don't care how big your step is,
it's only one step at a time.
You can't do two steps
in one, you understand?
So it's like one step at a time
and you take steps in this direction,
you take steps in that direction.
Sort of get lost along the way
and sometimes you fall down.
To illustrate my point, I'm
going to jump off the table
do a back twist and land on the floor.
Okay, is that cool, are you ready?
- [girl in Audience]
There's a clock there.
- There's a clock there?
Okay can you move the
clock for a second please?
Beautiful, beautiful all right.
You ready, so are, are you guys ready?
Just let me know when you're ready.
(crowd agreement)
Are you ready?
Okay ready 1, 2 ...
I'm joking man are you serious?
Just put the clock back there.
If I do that, I'll break my arm
or something you know what I mean?
(laughter)
But honestly along the way you might
fall down like this
ready? (whistles) (boom)
(laughter)
(laughs) Hello.
So what do you do when you fall down?
- [Audience] Get back up.
- Get back up, everybody
knows to get back up
because if I start walking,
I'm not going to get anywhere.
(laughter)
But I tell you there is sometimes in life
where you fall down and you feel like
you don't have the
strength to get back up.
You sort of put a mask on your face when
you come to school and
pretend that everything's okay
when it's not and you go
home and lay in your bed
when no one's looking at you,
when you don't have to impress anybody,
and you're yourself.
And fear comes in, you
know the fear that you have
as soon as you walk into
the doors of your house
maybe there's a broken home.
Maybe you have doubt in your life.
Maybe you don't know for
sure what's going to be
happening in the future and it scares you.
Maybe you're worried about
what people think of you,
what people say about you.
Just that fear paralyzes you and
I just want to ask you today,
do you think you have hope?
Because I tell you, I'm down here,
face down,
and I have no arms, no legs.
It should be impossible
for me to get back up.
I mean you go home and
tie the legs and arms
of your brothers and sisters
and like push them down,
and see how long it's going
to take them to get back up.
You know what I mean?
You know you can tell them
that you'll see them tomorrow,
you know what I mean?
(laughter)
This is the thing, it should be impossible
for me to get back up, but it's not.
You see, I will try 100 times to get up
and if I fail 100 times ...
If I fail and I give up, do you think
that I'm ever going to get up?
No.
But if I fail I try again
and again and again,
for as long as I try,
there's always that chance
of getting up, does that make sense?
(audience affirms)
And it's not the end
until you've given up.
And just the fact that you're here
should persuade you that
you have another chance
to get back up.
There's still hope.
I'm not here today to tell you that
I understand your pain.
I don't know how it feels to be abused.
I don't know how it
feels to feel "fat" and
you got an eating disorder.
I don't know how it feels
to have a broken home.
but I know how it feels
to have a broken heart.
And I know how it feels to be alone.
And I want you to know that I found
my strength in Jesus Christ
and you're going to find
your strength in whatever you find it in.
But I just want you to
know that it's not the end.
It matters how you're going to finish.
Are you going to finish strong?
And you will find that strength
to get back up like this.
(audience claps)
My passion is to encourage people,
To inspire people to be
all that they can be.
I found my purpose.
I found my strength and
I want you to find yours.
Don't be afraid of failing.
Every time you fall down,
every time you fail,
You learn something new.
You're ready for the next one.
You've learned how not to do something.
Well then learn from it and move on.
Leave what's behind and press forward.
You can only win if you don't give up.
Go for it, don't let
anything hold you back.
If nothing's holding me back,
what's holding you back?
I want to make sure that every
single day that you are alive
that you make it count and
you take the sweeter choices
of life that God has given you.
Because I want to ask you right now,
if this was your last
thirty seconds to breathe,
how would you be remembered?
Were you a giver, encourager
or were you a taker?
Were you a bitter person?
Did you encourage people to,
in your actions, in your life
did you help them or
did you discourage them?
Did you take that time
to say hey how you doing
and they look to the ground
and say oh you know I'm okay.
No look at me, how are you doing?
We are here for one another.
This is the ministry.
This is Jesus.
This is the light.
And I want to tell you, I
am sure if any one of us
was at a road and there
was a three year old kid
in the middle of the street sitting down,
playing with rocks in the
street and a bus was coming
and the bus was about to kill him,
you have plenty of time
to get up off your seat,
go save that kid.
Will you save that kid?
Of course you will.
You don't know his name,
you're going to save that kid.
You don't know his religion,
You don't know his sexual orientation,
you're going to save that kid.
Because why?
We are the light and love and
the bridge to Jesus Christ.
We need to understand that's it's not just
doing what we think we
need to achieve or have.
Some people think that things get easier
when you get married, uh uh.
Go talk to some married people.
(laughter)
Some single people are
like, oh I'm not happy
but I know I'm going to be
happy when I get married.
Dude if you ain't happy single,
you ain't going to be happy married.
Can he hear an amen?
- [Congregation] Amen.
- Yeah you guys already know it right,
you could have told me that.
So what do you want?
How do you act?
Who are you?
Make today count.
Dream big.
And never give up.
The world is a hurting place
and the world needs hope
and the world needs love.
Without hope, we feel
like why are we here?
Well brokenness, here's mine.
Today, I still have no arms, no legs,
but everything's changed, everything.
For me I was looking
for hope and happiness
and I couldn't see it for many years.
In fact if this side of the
table represents my hope,
truth encourages me to
become more than I can be.
But then we have lies everyday,
come into our mind,
people who discourage us.
You know the people that
you have in your life who,
no matter how good of a day you're having,
they'll bring you down?
Or no matter how bad
of a day you're having,
they'll bring you even lower.
You know what I'm talking about?
Think of the three biggest
discouragers in your life.
They're not your biggest
discouragers, you are.
You are.
You're going to take three
seconds for me to tell you
something discouraging but then,
you may never forget my words.
I've met so many 50 year old
women and 40 year old women
who still remember what
their father's told them,
that they wish they never heard.
Words are powerful.
When you hear those words and
then your mind starts
growing with these lies,
Nick you're not good enough.
Nick just give up.
Nick you're never going to get a job.
You won't get married.
You can't even hold your wife's hand.
What kind of a father are you going to be
if you can't even pick up
your kids when they're crying.
You're alone.
Sure your parents hug you,
but their hugs can't heal you.
Just give up.
At age eight I thought that
I should commit suicide.
Why because I didn't have hope.
I thought I didn't have hope.
Today you can see that I had hope.
What's the word, believing
in something you do not see?
Faith.
Words can only do so much.
Hugs can do much more than words,
but when hugs can't do anything,
that's where faith kicks in.
For me, words and hugs were not enough
but I had no faith.
There are times in life when
you don't see the purpose
or the good in your situation.
But just because you can't see it,
it doesn't mean it's not coming.
Who goes to the train station,
looks down the railway
and says augh the train's
not here, I'm leaving.
You will wait for the train why?
Because the schedule says
that the train is coming.
So just because you can't see
the hope in your situation,
it doesn't mean that it's not there.
You see, many people think
that I have only one foot,
just cause you can't see the other one.
I have gone from a life without limbs
into a life with out limits.
What about you?
- [Nick] The world is a hurting place
and the world needs hope
and world needs love.
My parents always taught me that
even though we don't know
why I was born this way,
that we have a choice either to be angry
for what we don't have or be
thankful for what we do have.
- I'm here in Slovenia.
I am so amazed, the trains here are
so so fast!
Did you see that one?
See that's what I'm saying it's so fast.
(laughter)
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Max and GTSE asked me too.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Nick's top ten rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
And finally I wanted to give a
quick shout out to Karen Setia.
Karen thank you so much for
buying a copy of my book.
It means a lot to me.
For those of you watching,
if you want your chance
at a shout out in a future video,
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching and
continue to believe or
whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you soon.
(loud swoosh)
- Hi everyone, it's Nick Vujicic.
You'll never believe
what we're doing today.
We're here in Dallas Fort
Worth with American Airlines.
We're doing something
that I always entertained
in my mind to try doing.
And that's to dress up
in a pilot's uniform
and greet the passengers
as they go on the plane,
courtesy of Captain Glenn Thompson ...
Captain Glenn Thompson
what are we doing today?
- Well Nick what we're doing
is, we're fulfilling Nick's
dream about being an airline captain.
We're on flight 247
today from Dallas to LAX
and we're going to have you up
there greeting your passengers.
And you're going to do
inspirational, motivating talk
to everybody and you are
going to be the man today.
(laughter)
I am subordinate to you today sir.
So you're the captain of this flight.
I heard Nick had a dream
to be an airline captain.
I saw him speaking at Lakewood
Church with Joel Olsteen
and I saw him speaking and
I actually brought tears to my eyes.
And I said I can make that happen and
American Airlines is the company to do it.
And we're here today to
fill your dream Nick,
fulfill your dream.
- I can't believe it's happening.
- [pilot] That should work right?
- Yeah, I think it's true.
Welcome aboard.
I'm your captain today,
where you chit chat with.
I'm trying out some new technology.
Have a great day flight,
and I'll talk to you soon.
(laughter)
- [pilot] All right captain.
Thank you captain Nick.
- Bet you'll be flying with brain today.
- [passenger] Oh really huh.
- I've got some new
technology we're trying out.
- [passenger] How fun.
- Yeah, welcome aboard.
- Oh yeah you do that.
- [passenger] I am from
the same place as you.
- Oh where you from?
- [passenger] Near Zurich.
- Near Zurich, well man I'm Aussie.
- [passenger] You are then?
- Yeah, what's more freak
about me flying the plane?
The fact that I'm Aussie or
the fact that I have no arms or legs?
- [passenger] You're an Aussie.
(laughter)
- I love it.
I love it.
You're awesome, here we are.
- [passenger] Thanks man.
- Bye man. (mumbles)
- Take care man.
- [passenger] Hey enjoy your flight.
- Thanks cheers.
- Hi how are you?
- [passenger] How are you?
- Good.
- [passenger] A flight that
you haven't been on before.
- I'm actually going to be fly it then.
- [passenger] Cool.
- I'm the captain.
Enjoy.
(laughter)
- Doing really well.
Notice my palms are sweaty a little bit.
I'll be flying the plane today.
(laughter)
- We're trying out some new technology.
Today I'll be flying
the plane, so uh yeah.
- [passenger] That'd be fun.
- [passenger] I'm excited.
- Are you good.
- [passenger] I'm kind of wired.
- Me too.
I'm a little nervous,
my knees are shaking.
(laughter)
- [passenger] It's voice
activated controls?
- Brain waves actually.
(laughter)
- Home speaker above my head.
- Hopefully non of you get
distracting me alright?
(laughter)
- We just boarded the whole plane.
It was really funny, some
people were like okay.
Some were like uh, really?
Like how are you controlling that?
I was like brain waves, I have no idea.
So cool, the kids were like what?
Some people are just
like cool, it was cool.
When you were talking
about the new technology,
what did they say?
- Just total, is this guy
really safe to fly an airplane
because he doesn't know
what he's talking about.
They were like set up.
- Did they say that?
Did they say that?
- They're are like are you sure its ...
You know that oh my God this guys
going to take me into the air
and he's telling me this
funky stuff this ...
It was funny.
I love it.
- It was great.
Go get yours, thank you.
All right good time.
Lets greet the passengers.
How was your boarding?
It was a mutual on board
as your captain wizard
and that is the new
technology that we have.
We are your first captain
without arms and legs
flying the plane.
We have some great new
brain wave technology
and just pray that I
don't get too distracted.
I think that it will be okay.
Just do what I do, hold on
with both hands, we'll be fine.
Good morning guys, I'll be your--
- [passenger] Good morning.
- Were you nervous a little
bit when I told the news?
- Yeah.
- Tell me, what did you like,
what did you want to do?
Like oh my gosh.
- Yeah I was really scared.
- Ha ha.
- Not of you the pilot
but of the technology--
- [Nick] Oh the technology.
- [passenger] Yeah.
- [Nick] Yeah that's cool.
- You think that American would
pull it off that they get--
- There's no such technology
that brain waves (mumbles)
- [Nick] (mumbling)
- Definitely don't force him.
- How you all doing, how ya doing?
- Can't complain.
- Were you scared when
I came up, you weren't?
- No.
- Were you a little bit?
- [Nick] Except your face (mumble)
(laughter)
- We're training.
- I thought it was new technology.
- We have new technology,
are you guys ready for that?